[Music]
i love being incontinent
i love being in congress i delight to
the senses isn't it my friend
isn't it
[Music]
so glad we could bring this project to
this neighborhood it's so rich in
history yeah i grew up in a neighborhood
like this oh yeah i i grew up in a
neighborhood exactly like this
all right welcome to mama's sugar bags
y'all ready to order yeah
can i have a chicken fried steak with
gravy and a cola okay
i will have the baked beef short ribs
with collard greens and throw down some
of that cornbread
all right babe
you know what
hold up a second i'm also gonna have
some of the collard greens and cornbread
as well but hook a brother up with some
of them hot links all right all right
you know what uh why am i trying to
front scratch all that give me some okra
and some fried red snapper and girl you
know i want some chitlins all right man
y'all got ham hocks
of course well that's what i want i want
to play the ham hocks deep fried
blackened and served on a bed of mustard
greens pig feet
i want some pig feet and four pounds of
grits and oh oh you know what else give
me a little dixie cup full of lard all
right i just remember what i want a bowl
of mosquitoes
none of them tiny ones either give me
them big [ __ ] to find down at
the swamp sister
could you please hook a brother up with
a rusty bucket full of fish heads
wrapped in razor wire donk your teeth
dunk your teeth straight out a donkey's
mouth you know what okay any animal
tooth will do i want you to stick it in
some honey glaze fry it with fat back
and serve it in an old tin coffee can
forget everything i said up to this
point right now bring me some dandelion
greens a cow hip and a dog face wrap
that whole mess in an old ebony magazine
and serve it to me in a shoe box okay i
want a platter of stork ankles an old
cellar door a possum spine
and a human
foot
you want a human foot
mm-hmm
i got just one question for y'all
you want gravy on that cellar though
oh definitely oh yeah yeah
this place is so nice
this is
supposed to be one of the best uh french
places in town
i did not realize that you were so
cultured
you're sweet
uh
my french is
pretty good
so uh i can order for both of us
bonjour welcome to che de la morton
berendra i am your waiter for this
evening my name is jean-luc de la pierre
renault but you may call me jean
oh look at you well if you have any
questions about anything at all i'm more
than happy to uh assist you on twitter
i got it
well our first special tonight is our
poisson du jour is a loop de mercu of
the song
served with a plumer vert de cochon
diplomat that is served on a pedestrian
with just a dash of shenton bertrand and
served with the melted piston chamber
soup yeah our other seafood today we
have a very nice flamethrower crown
deposit vance from the gutson museum
valley in vesseltown it is served with
the side of colombo fontone de la mata
do god
from here cologne sauce
man it's just
i'm a little bit overwhelmed
yes oh god i'm so glad you said that i
was about to say the same thing so you
would recommend getting the flonta pan
grand dump
with the um oh i'm sorry is the pillow
right
and a heavy falls on that sauce oh no no
no
what do you think i'm i'm gonna defer to
him on this one because he knows this
stuff way better than i do
miss you
what what
yeah we're uh we'll have the
song
uh
it's been nice knowing you have a lovely
dinner
[Music]
excuse me i think we're ready to order
well
um i'm sorry that's not how things work
in this establishment someone will come
to you yes we're sorry no no problem
what was that
what well where was black jeff
black jeff what
yeah
black jeff
i read somewhere that when you dated
biracial guy you're supposed to get the
best of both worlds so there are white
jeff situations and there are black jeff
situations and that was definitely a
black jeff situation
oh
okay okay hi folks i'm so sorry for the
wait can i get you bottled or tap water
for the table this evening how about i
bottle your ass and kick it down the
stairs man we've been waiting half an
hour for one of you [ __ ] to
show up god i'm so i'm so sorry i'll get
you a bottle of our finest premium water
on the house that's what i said [ __ ]
sorry what are you doing what black jeff
that was black jeffy but he was just
trying to help us
oh so white white jeff yes
good evening i'm sorry to bother you two
i am the maitre d here at chey henry oh
yes uh what is it
i am so sorry to disturb you both but
our establishment has a certain dress
code and madame's um
decolletage is inappropriate oh my god
we're we're very sorry we didn't know
there was a dress code we'll certainly
remember for the next time but there
ain't gonna be no next time for you
looking at my woman and her her
deco choco chocolate or whatever you
said man there a problem here okay see
it was really a simple misunderstanding
it all started with that [ __ ]
right there who was disrespecting myself
and my girl but we really love this guy
and he gave us exceptional assertions
we're gonna have to ask you to leave you
have to ask me to leave oh you have to
ask the black man to leave huh actually
you don't have to ask us to leave we
just want to see ourselves out and we
ain't never coming back again though we
really appreciate your help that's it
what's your ass man let us reimburse you
for that breakage okay right after i'll
burn this whole place with a
[ __ ] ground with everybody
inside of it by which i mean you're
gonna get a very negative review on yelp
you will be in room 237
and you have free wi-fi there also from
6am to 10am every morning there's a free
continental breakfast
continental breakfast yes from 6am to
10am
so it's continental then
very good
like garcon
a one uh admission for the continental
breakfast
you can just help yourself sir
interesting european style
[Music]
when
in
rome
[Music]
the forbidden fruit
well aren't you a tiny plum
well la
di
da
[Music]
vapor in everything
and who are you
my little friend
not a spoon
not a fork but something in between
a fappoon
[Music]
what will you think of next germany
all the european countries lay before me
where should i fly to first
the pit of the donut
thank you turkey
buckle up
let's see where we shall go next ah the
danish
clearly from brussels um
hello grease
where the yogurt flows like water
yes
like go good but to stay
so good
pulling into spain
[Music]
baked to perfection
and you believe this it all comes with
the room
[Music]
i love being incontinent
i love being uncomfortable i delight to
the senses isn't it my friend
isn't it
yes
i have what i'm having
[Music]
what i'm having
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's so
good
oh good afternoon sir how can i help you
well
davis i will be staying
indefinitely
but sir don't you know that you've
always been here
[Music]
really
[Music]
continental breakfast
right around the corner
[Music]
first time for you first time yes
so what's good oh what i'll tell you
right you have to have the kebabi kebap
is what you're going to have okay oh
don't they serve that in the cafe across
the street no
you cannot give me the puppy at the cafe
across the street
what what did i say across the street in
san penny
this cafe
macedonian
my friends
i like to apologize for the behavior of
my passion
i just feel bad in my brain for people
to think that your mouths will have been
raped but the food that they serving at
these albanian mother [ __ ]
these mother [ __ ] sons of my [ __ ]
across the street what they be serving
is chevape
and and what do you serve here
okay
but they don't know
no
i have to forgive them right easter in a
nicer booth
for the bastard mother [ __ ] over
there that are serving the chevape
brought in the grilled meat
salt
chopped red pepper diced onion cream
cashmark iceberg
then the cottage cheese
what are you serving
we serve the kebab
and we put in the courage cheese
the cash mac
the cream you know then it's the diced
onions it sounds exactly like fat
and then the grilled meat
then the grilled meat
and then we stir it
and across the street they do those
mother [ __ ] over there they mix it
their sons
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
this season my friends now
it is time for you to try the real good
fool not
what these sun um my [ __ ] serve
across the street
mcdonald's sure yeah i'll make sure to
give us the five stars on yelp
[Laughter]
god the moment i saw you last night at
the club i totally had to ask you out
yeah are you kidding me like the moment
oh yeah that's so sweet i was actually
afraid that you were going to be like
one of those high maintenance chicks
yeah
what yeah
i don't know i don't control freak or i
don't even know i don't know thank god
that's so funny isn't it
is it is it funny is fun nah i'm like i
totally just like to be
like easy going yeah yeah i win i'll be
here in five minutes and we're just now
getting our menus
oh i'm sorry
don't be sorry
be better
right okay i'll be better that's your
job
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so yeah my philosophy is pretty much
like keep it chill
right yeah yeah you know what i like
about you no what like you're not afraid
to be like brainy and respectful right
thanks i really like your boobs
i think we really compliment each other
well just did it right there
and uh i pretty much go with the flow
right right
is wrong with you
[Music]
excuse me do i look like mad max to you
i'm sorry do i look like mel gibson with
a mullet
no not not at all does he look like a
feral child with a boomerang in his hand
no then why is water a rare commodity
here it's not it's not i'm just uh
i'm sorry i'm just really slammed
you'll know when you're slammed because
your nuts will be on the table and my
fists will be covered in your blood
[Music]
um
you were uh like kind of harsh to that
guy
oh him yeah no
i was a hostess at a restaurant in the
industry that's how we talk to each
other i'll show you hey oh god uh hey
what do you see there
that's your water
down
down down boy look
then you need okay i have other tables
that i have
what does that look like to you
yes there's a little lipstick on your
glasses but it mean it's yours this is
what i want you to do i want you to take
this glass in the back
i want you to break it
take the biggest shard you can find and
bring it to me
and i'm gonna slit your color
all right i'm just i'll get you another
one i'm gonna split your throat
and watch you bleed out
and i'm gonna shower in your blood all
right
i'll get another water well that would
be great thank you
but as i was saying like i just feel
like it's like do unto others
it was your lipstick on the glass
what the hell is that what are you doing
wait wait no no no no
oh my god
i just tell you
no one's ever
talked to me like that in my voice
have his back
who does that it was your lipstick on
the glass he's just a waiter
you know what take his side i hope you
have a very happy life together
make it
what's going on right now
what do you do
[Music]
seriously me again no
no
megan you left the jacket hey you left
your check hey
don't do it
i mean i just hurt her feelings and then
she left her jacket at least i could do
it backward jack don't do it
she's not needed it's 87 degrees out you
know she doesn't need it in your heart
of hearts you know she doesn't need that
jacket
don't do it
[Music]
i think she's gonna need a jacket she's
not going to be
seemed like a nice guy
give me both of them man okay
i decide which one i want when i want to
eat it
maybe you uh you want some of these
vegetables too
no
no
just saying man
the nutrients is good
for maintaining energy levels so
i know what the vegetable is man don't
don't tell me what a vegetable is man
i'm hey
i'm a grown ass man
all right
yeah i'm sorry
this three being salad is the bomb
though oh snack
they got three bean salad up in there
mm-hmm i ain't even see that
you want some of mine
yeah okay
open the hangar
what you doing
nah you don't do that
you don't feed me like a kid man
i'm a grown ass man
okay y'all see why you got some schmutz
right here hey hey hey
on my face
you don't know touch a grown man's face
yup that's right i'm sorry okay
you all are grown ass hey hey
i don't need you to pat my back i'm a
grown ass man what you doing
i know you're going i don't want to hear
it anymore about grown-ass man ah that's
what i am i don't want to hear you are
you
treating me like you're clean
this is not the place for this country
don't start acting up here because
you're making me angry um okay then i
need you to breathe a little bit can you
breathe
[Music]
i want a [ __ ] inside voice up
in this [ __ ] don't be getting loud up
around these white people you
um
[Music]
oh oh i'm sorry i'm sorry you're a grown
ass man you're a grown-ass man
are you a who's a grown ass man you're a
grown ass man
you're a grown ass man right
you know what grown ass man do you go to
the bathroom and change your pants with
your itp right yeah yeah okay let's go
excuse me everybody
um
i'm sorry but my son got that benjamin
buttons disease
oh
he's four reforms recording
thank yous for meeting me here yeah of
course you know he's glad we could set
aside our differences and avoid the war
here you know
all right salute
[Music]
[Music]
no
that's too much what are you doing we're
just having a nice little dinner here
all right well that's just disrespectful
oh no not his head he had good hair yeah
you're done you already messed up
what are you doing now
this phone no no no don't go deleting
his contacts he's not gonna know where
to answer it or not you're finished now
that's that's good look what you did now
we were in the middle of sonoma today
and now whatever
what's going on what are you doing
oh that's permanent that's a permanent
silly mustache oh now he looks like a
sleeping musketeer that's adorable but
it's it's ridiculous he can't he can
hardly wash that off that's it whatever
where you going
what is that nah what the what are you
doing yeah you're putting in this game
that doesn't even make sense here that
doesn't even make sense
oh oh anthony oh that's hilarious but
save that for a slumber party all right
what are you no you're rearranging the
silverware that's just so mean it's it's
confusing it's confusing enough what
what the hell
hit me don't do oh well you know the
salad you get a little pepper so that's
good that's so that's that's not so bad
you finally did something constructive
what are you looking for what are you
you're putting the silverware back
that's good
that's good now he knows he can go from
outside to inside and that's oh
you put a little zhu in his head that's
good yeah [ __ ] just oh now it actually
looks better than when he came in if he
wasn't unconscious he could go out on
the town so that's good that's good oh
look here you go all right white wipe
off his face yeah yeah get the mustache
while you're at it because that's that's
the most embarrassing part oh he doesn't
look ridiculous anymore oh okay now
that's that's now you're helping
everybody that's good for everybody
everybody likes that nobody wants
lettuce on the floor
[Music]
all right we done all right you really
turned this around at me there he's all
right and then your garnish all right
all right he won't even know what hit
him he won't even know that any
oh no
no no no no anthony eddie i can see it
in your eyes i can see it in your eyes
you're going the other way now anthony
and he was going so well
well that's that's that's perverse
hearing me i don't even know what what's
that what's that what you gonna do with
that finger what are you oh
yeah no not a wet
war willy we're going to war
we're going to war
[Music]